Ich bin heute der Bekannte und werde das erste Gespräch mit Ihnen führen.
Erstmal benötige ich ein paar persönliche Daten von Ihnen und dann sprechen wir über Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden.
Was Sie fragen haben, suggen Sie bitte nicht mich zu unterbrechen. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Hans-Jörg Kaiser.
Hans-Jörg ist ein Doppelname, oder?
Ja, ja. Hans-Jörg.
Ich beschreibere mal eben K-A-I-S-E-R.
Hans-Jörg. Hans.
Nein, nein. Nachnamen. K-A-I-S-E-R.
Ja, richtig. Kaiser.
Vorname H-A-N-S-Linea-J-Ö-R-K-E-K.
Ja.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Kaiser?
Ja, ich bin 74, Herr Doktor.
Ihr Gebustdatum bitte.
Ja, 20. Juni 1951.
Wissen Sie, wie groß Sie sind?
Ja, ich bin 1 Meter 82.
Ihr Gewicht bitte.
Ja, ich wiege ungefähr 80 Kilogramm.
Haben Sie einen Hausarzt oder eine Hausärztin, Herr Kaiser?
Ja, mein Hausarzt heißt Florian Wiltz.
Florian Wiltz. Ja.
Was fühlt Sie heute zu uns, Herr Kaiser?
Welche Beschwerden haben Sie?
Ja, Herr Doktor, ich huste.
Ja, meine Hauptbeschwerde ist husten.
Aber ich habe auch fortschreitende Atemnot.
Ich kann nicht gut atmen, ich kann nicht kriegen.
Seit zwei Jahren habe ich ähnliche Beschwerden.
Aber seit sechs Monaten ist es schlimm geworden.
Aber seit fünf Tagen bin ich sehr schlimm.
Ich kann nicht liegen, ich muss immer kriegen.
Das ist sehr schlimm, Herr Doktor.
Seit fünf Tagen besonders wird es schlimm.
Besonders, ja.
Ich kann sagen, dass es schlimmste Hüstenattacken sind.
Das ist sehr schlimm.
Haben Sie trockene Hüsten oder Hüsten mit Auswurf?
Ja, ich habe Auswurf, aber das ist chronisch.
Ich habe immer Auswurf.
Wie ist das Auswurf?
Manchmal gelb, manchmal weiß.
Manchmal sehr, manchmal dünnsichtig.
Es gibt immer unterschiedliche.
Besonders morgens muss ich immer Auswurf entwerfen.
Haben Sie Blut im Auswurf bemerkt?
Manchmal merke ich Blut auch.
Haben Sie Atemnot?
Ja, manchmal leide ich unter Atemnot.
Aber seit fünf Tagen kann ich nicht fünf Treppen steigen.
Ich muss immer warten, ausruhen.
Ich kann nicht 200 Meter laufen, Herr Doktor.
Wie viele Etage können Sie ohne Pause steigen?
Nach fünf Etagen. Ich muss pauseieren.
Fünf Treppen oder?
Ja, fünf Treppen.
Haben Sie pfeifende Atemgeräusche gehört, Herr Kaiser?
Manchmal habe ich auch pfeifende Geräusche.
Aber wenn ich spaziere, bin ich total außer Puste.
Früher ging das alles nur, aber jetzt schnaufe ich wie ein Lokomotiv.
Haben Sie Einatmungsstörungen oder Probleme beim Einatmen oder Ausatmen?
Besonders Ausatmen ist schwerer als Einatmen.
Letzten Jahr habe ich 10 Kilo abgenommen.
Seit wann?
Seit einem Jahr.
Waren Sie schon?
Manchmal habe ich einen sehr schleimigen Auswurf.
Richtig ähnlich.
Was meinen Sie damit?
Das ist wie gelb-grün und schleimig.
Das ist ähnlich.
Mein Auswurf ist besonders mohles.
Haben Sie Hessgasen oder Hessstolpen bemerkt?
Wenn ich treppe steige, fühle ich meinen Herzschlag sehr schnell.
Richtig.
Haben Sie Schwellungen in den Beinen bemerkt, Herr Kaiser?
Manchmal habe ich Schwellungen.
Aber in den letzten Tagen habe ich Schwellungen.
Ich habe auch ein enges Gefühl, Herr Doktor.
Wie wenn jemand auf meinem Brust sitzt.
Wenn ich besonders spaziere, wenn ich treppe steige.
Momentan haben Sie ein enges Gefühl?
Wenn ich besonders treppe steige oder wenn ich leuche, fühle ich.
Aber jetzt haben Sie keine, oder?
Jetzt ja. In Ruhe nicht.
Haben Sie Fieber? Fühlen Sie sich schwierig?
Nein, ich habe keine Fieber.
Haben Sie dagegen irgendwelche Medikamente genommen, Herr Kaiser?
Ich nutze immer zwei Spray.
Wie heißt das?
Herr Doktor, ich nutze einen Ventolin und Kombivent Spray.
Aber ich habe keine Dosisierung.
Seit zwei Jahren nutze ich das.
Hat es Ihnen geholfen?
In den letzten fünf Tagen hilft mir nichts.
Ich fühle mich schlechter als.
Aber normalerweise helfen sie mir.
Haben Sie Nachschweiß?
Nachschweiß, ja. Seit einer Woche habe ich Nachschweiß.
Sie haben recht.
Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie können nicht liegen.
Beim Schlafen, wie viele Kopfkisten nutzen Sie?
Ja, in der letzten Woche muss ich immer mit zwei Kisten schlafen.
Und ich fühle mich total schlapp und kraftlos.
Besonders im Kaltwetter.
Im Kaltwetter ist es schlimmer.
Herr Kaiser, wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Appetit ist in der letzten Woche auch schlecht.
Nicht gut.
Ist Ihnen übel?
Wegen Ausrufs habe ich manchmal Übelkeit.
Müssen Sie sich übergeben?
Nein, nein.
Wie ist Ihr Stuhlgang und Wasserlassen?
Stuhlgang und Wasserlassen sind nicht schlimm.
Aber ich habe eine größere Vorstandsdürre.
Deswegen stehe ich zweimal auf wegen Wasserlassen.
Ab abends?
Ab abends, ja.
Das heißt, Sie können nicht gut schlafen?
Ja, mein Schlaf ist total kaputt.
Habt ihr einen Schlaf oder einen Durchschlaf?
Normalerweise muss ich wegen Durchschlafen aufwachen.
Aber in der letzten Woche war mein Schlaf ganz schlecht.
Haben Sie außer Vergrößerung von chronischen Krankheiten?
Ich leide unter Bluthochdruck seit 10 Jahren.
Und Zuckerkrankheit seit 15 Jahren.
Seit 15 Jahren.
Seit wann haben Sie eine vorstehende Vergrößerung?
Seit 7 Jahren.
Was nehmen Sie gegen Bluthochdruck?
Ich nehme Metoprolol 25 mg täglich.
Norvask 10 mg täglich.
Und Hydrochlorothiazid 12,5 mg zweimal.
Hydrochlorothiazid in welcher Dosis?
12,5 mg.
Zweimal täglich.
Und Antiprostat Tablet 4 mg täglich.
Antiprostat. 4 mg.
4 mg, ja.
Was nehmen Sie gegen Zuckerkrankheit?
Metformin 500 mg, zweimal täglich.
Würden Sie schon einmal operiert, Herr Kaiser?
Ja, ich würde auch hinzufügen.
Als ich Kind war, hatte ich eine dringende Entzündung.
Das war 15 Tage, da habe ich im Krankenhaus geblieben.
Wurde bei Ihnen eine stationäre Behandlung durchgeführt?
Ja, 15 Tage.
Und der Arzt hat meiner Mutter gesagt, dass ich gestorben war.
Tut mir leid zu hören, Herr Kaiser, aber Gott sei Dank, Sie sind hier.
Gott sei Dank, ich habe 75 Jahre gelebt.
In welchem Alter waren Sie?
Als ich 7 war.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, meine Gallenblase vor 20 Jahren entfand.
Vor 20 Jahren.
Sie haben schon gesagt, seit zwei Jahren leiden Sie an Husten und Atemnot.
Waren Sie deswegen beim Arzt?
Ja, ich war beim Arzt. Ich war immer unter Kontrolle.
Er hat mir gesagt, dass das eine chronische Lungenentzündung ist.
Wurde bei Ihnen eine Festdiagnose gestellt?
Mein Arzt hat mir gesagt, dass das eine chronische entzündliche Lungenentzündung ist.
Chronische entzündliche Lungenerkrankung.
Ja, chronische obstruktive Lungenentzündung.
Gibt es irgendetwas, das Sie beschwerden? Schlimmer oder besser?
Ja, feuchte Wetter.
Außer morgen oder an der Liga?
Ja, ich kann nicht jetzt liegen. Wenn ich bewege, hat es schlimmer.
Es hat sich schlimmer und ich kann nicht gut bewegen.
Herr Kaiser, rauchen Sie?
Ja, Gott sei Dank habe ich vor fünf Jahren aufgehört.
Gut zu hören. Vorher haben Sie wie viele Zigaretten täglich geraucht?
Ja, 40 Jahre habe ich eineinhalb Schachtel Zigaretten geraucht.
Es ist zu viel. Herr Kaiser, Sie haben eine gute Entscheidung getroffen, mit dem Rauchen aufzuhören.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke nicht Herr Doktor. Alkohol gefällt mir nicht.
Haben Sie nichts getrunken?
Nein, nein, niemand.
Bitte nehmen Sie die folgenden Fragen nicht persönlich aus medizinischen Gründen.
Fragen Sie mir immer. Haben Sie Erfahrung mit Drogen?
Nein, Herr Doktor, ich war Lehrer. Deswegen musste ich Vorbild sein.
Ich bin immer gegen Drogen. Ich habe gekämpft gegen Drogen.
Sehr gut gesagt. Haben Sie Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten?
Ich hatte auch ein halbes Jahr Allergien.
Sie sind auch ein paar Jahre alt?
Ja, ich habe mit dem Schnaufen getrennt.
Haben Sie noch andere Allergien?
Nein.
Sind Sie verheiratet, Herr Kaiser?
Ja, ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Haben Sie mit Ihren Ehepraus zusammen?
Ja, ja, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe zwei Töchter.
Sind Sie gesund?
Sie sind gesund, ja.
Gut.
Gibt es irgendwelche chronischen Erkrankungen in Ihrer Familie?
Mein Vater ist vor zehn Jahren an Herzinfarkten gestorben.
Wie alt war er?
Er war 88.
Wie alt ist Ihre Mutter?
Meine Mutter ist ganz gesund. Sie ist 92 und ganz gesund.
Sie ist gut. Sie ist alt und gesund.
Ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich hatte einen Bruder.
Er ist vor 15 Jahren an Herzinfarkten gestorben.
Wie alt war er?
Er war 65.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft, Herr Kaiser?
Ja, ich hatte alle empfohlenen Impfungen.
Gut. Waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Nein, nein, nein.
Sie haben schon gesagt, seit einem Jahr 10 Kilogramm abgenommen.
Ja, ja, Herr Doktor.
All das ungewollt, Herr Kaiser?
Ja, normalerweise. Ich achte meine Ernährung.
Ich esse nicht viel.
Seit wann haben Sie wenig Appetit?
Wenig Appetit ist seit besonders zehn Tagen.
Aber es ist unangenehm, 10 Kilo abzunehmen, denke ich.
Sie haben keinen Fieber, keinen Nachschweiß?
Nachschweiß habe ich.
Aber nichts Fieber?
Ich habe Fieber, aber ich fühle mich nicht fieberlich.
Sie haben Schwellung in den Beinen?
Ja, ja, ja.
Oder?
Ja, in beiden Beinen.
Einerseits habe ich alle wichtigen Fragen gestellt.
Herr Kaiser, möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Herr Doktor, natürlich habe ich Angst. Was kann ich haben?
Ich möchte etwas Genaues sagen, Herr Kaiser.
Jetzt werde ich eine körperliche Untersuchung durchschauen.
Danach werde ich Labouruntersuchungen durchschauen.
Und eine operative Diagnostik durchschauen.
Mit diesen Ergebnissen können wir entscheiden.
Welche operative Diagnostik möchten Sie durchschauen? Ich verstehe nicht.
Operative Diagnostik bedeutet bildgebende Diagnostik, bildgebende Untersuchung.
Ich werde ein EKG schreiben und ein Röntgen veranlassen, Herr Kaiser.
Röntgen sind sehr hoch in Strahlung.
Es ist nur gering. Es enthält nur gering Strahlung.
Machen Sie sich deswegen keine Sorgen, bitte.
Ich habe alle zwei Monate ein Röntgen.
Sie haben seit zwei Jahren eine Überrüstung und Atemnot.
Deswegen sollten Sie die Ärzte mit Röntgen veranlassen.
Herr Doktor, was muss ich jetzt machen?
Bleiben Sie bitte hier.
Ich habe Atemnot.
Ich kann Ihnen Sauerstoff geben, Herr Kaiser.
Vielen Dank Herr Doktor.
Gerne.
Ich möchte Ihnen einen neuen Patienten vorstellen, den ich eben in der Notaufnahme gesehen habe.
Es handelt sich um Hans-Jörg Kaiser.
Er ist ein 74-jähriger Patient, geboren am 20.06.1951.
Er ist 1,82 Meter groß und 80 Kilogramm schwer.
Er stellt sich seit fünf Tagen vor, bestehende, zunehmende, bestehenden, zunehmenden,
mit gelblichem manchmal blutigem Ausdruck sowie Fatigue.
Darüber hinaus klagt er über Dyspnoea, besonders Bewegungsabhängige.
Dyspnoea berichtete, dass seit zwei Jahren Lungenerkrankungen gehabt haben.
Jedoch, die Beschwerden seien seit fünf Tagen schlimmer geworden.
Als Begleitsymptomen liegen ihm bewegungsabhängige Tachikade,
Oedema in beiden Beinen und Orthopne.
Deswegen nutzt er zwei Kopfkisten.
In der vegetativen Anamnese sind folgende Beschwerden bekannt.
Nachschweiß, Neusea, Inapetens, besonders seit zehn Tagen,
Gewichtabnahme innerhalb eines Jahres 10 Kilogramm, Nikturie und Insomnie.
Typ von Einschlafstörungen und Durchschlafstörungen.
An Vorerkrankungen leidet er seit sieben Jahren an Beninprostata Hiperfilasi.
Dagegen nimmt er Antiprosten 4 Milligramm einmal täglich ein.
So wie leidet er seit zehn Jahren an arterieller Hypertonie.
Dagegen nimmt er Metopolol 25 Milligramm einmal täglich.
Norvask 10 Milligramm einmal täglich.
Hydrochlorothiazid 12,5 Milligramm zweimal täglich ein.
Darüber hinaus leidet er seit 15 Jahren an Diabetes mellitus.
Dagegen nimmt er Metformin 500 Milligramm zweimal täglich ein.
Er hatte mit sieben Jahren eine Lungenentzündung.
Deswegen wurde bei ihm eine stationäre Behandlung durchgeführt.
Es hat 15 Tage.
Bei ihm wurde vor 20 Jahren eine Cholestektomie durchgeführt.
Er hatte eine Allergie gegen Hausstaub.
Er hat sich mit Rhinokonjunktivitis äußert.
Er ist Ex-Raucher.
Vor fünf Jahren hat er mit dem Rauchen aufgehört.
Davor 60 Packages.
Er trinke keinen Alkohol.
Er ist verheiratet.
Er lebt mit seiner Frau zusammen.
Er hat zwei gesunde Tochter.
In der Familienanamnese fand er sich.
Der Vater ist mit 88 Jahren an Herzinfarkt verstorben.
Er ist mit 65 Jahren an Lungenkrebs verstorben.
Die Mutter ist gesund.
Er ist vollständig geimpft.
Die Reiseanamnese ist unauffällig.
Ich habe es vergessen, Herr Oberast.
Er leidet seit zwei Jahren an Husten und Dysknoe.
Hausarzt hat gesagt, dass er chronische Lungenerkrankungen hatte.
Dagegen nimmt er Ventolin und Kombiventspray ein.
Seit zwei Tagen haben die Medikamente ihm nicht geholfen.
Meine Verdachtstiagnose lautet auf COPD-Exzersurbation.
Dafür leidet er.
Er hatte seit zwei Jahren Lungenerkrankungen.
Momentan hat er Dysknoe und Husten mit geltlichem Ausruf.
Er hat eine bewegungsabhängige Tachycardia.
Er hat eine Differenz.
Er hat Lungenkrebs und Bronchialkrebs.
Er hat Herzinsuffizienz.
Zuerst würde ich den Patienten eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Im Rahmen der Untersuchung würde ich zunächst die Vitalparameter erfassen.
Danach würde ich den Patienten inspizieren, palpieren und oskultieren.
Bei der Inspektion achte ich auf die Hautverfärbung im Lippen.
Bei der Oskultation oskultiere ich den Lungengeräusch.
Ich achte auf den Rassengeräusch.
So wie oskultiere ich Herzgeräusch.
Danach würde ich eine Labouruntersuchung durchführen.
Ich würde die Entzündungswerte, Troponinwerte, CKMB, Dedima, Leber und Nierenwerte durchführen.
Ich glaube, Yusuf ist gelaufen.
Er ist so gelaufen.
Er kann sich die Zeit stoppen.
Ich würde die Labouruntersuchung durchführen.
Ich würde die Entzündungswerte, Troponinwerte, CKMB, Dedima, Leber und Nierenwerte durchführen.
Danach würde ich die Diagnostik durchführen.
Zunächst würde ich einen EKG schreiben, um einen möglichen Coronär-Herstinfarkt auszuschließen.
Ich würde eine Blutgasanalyse durchführen, um eine Hulmonenembolie auszuschließen.
Ich würde eine Röntgenaufnahme des Thoraxes veranlassen.
Dabei können wir Herzvergrößerung und Lungenödeme erkennen oder darstellen.
Ich würde die CT-Thorax durchführen.
Er hat 10 kg Gewichtabnahme.
Um eine Lungenkrebsauszuschließen würde ich die CT-Thorax durchführen.
Um meine Verdachtsdiagnose zu bestätigen würde ich Spirometrie durchführen.
Um meine Verdachtsdiagnose zu bestätigen würde ich den Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Zunächst würde ich einen Venösezugang legen, um eine Venösetherapie zu ermöglichen.
Je nach Sauerstoffwerte würde ich eine Sauerstoffmaske geben.
Gegebenenfalls würde ich Beta-Mimetik, wie z.B. Salbutamol, Ventolin verabreichen.
Bei akutem Fall würde ich eine Glykokortikoide-Therapie verabreichen.
Das ist mein Therapieplan.
Herr Oberarzt, das würde ich durchführen.
Was empfehlen Sie den Patienten nach der Akutbehandlung?
Er ist mit dem Zigaretten aufgehört.
Ich empfehle ihm Kochsalzarmdiät, Fettsarmdiät, Gewichtskontrolle und regelmäßige körperliche Aktivität.
Herr Kollege, wie können Sie ein Herzinfizienz ausschließen?
Ich würde eine Echokardiographie durchführen.
Dabei können wir Herzwand- und Ejectionfraktion beurteilen.
Mit dieser Methode können wir ein Herzinsuffizienz ausschließen.
Und wie würden Sie ein Bronchialkarzinom ausschließen?
Ich würde ein CT-Thorax veranlassen.
Dabei können wir Tumorgewebe oder Lymphknoten darstellen.
Gegebenenfalls würde ich eine Bronchoscopie ausschließen.
Wann entscheiden Sie eine Bronchoscopie?
Wenn die beiden CT-Toraxen ungeheuer sind, sollten wir eine Bronchoscopie ausschließen.
Ich meine, jetzt während der Akutbehandlung oder nach der Akutbehandlung?
Nein, das ist keine Akutbehandlung.
Bei der Akutbehandlung sollten wir eine symptomatische Behandlung ausschließen.
Wenn wir zum Beispiel eine Glykokortik oder eine betamymetikale Agonistin sind,
können wir eine Bronchoscopie ausschließen.
Können Sie uns eine Bronchoscopie ausschließen?
Ja, Herr Oberast, eine Bronchoscopie ist eine operative Untersuchung.
Bei der können wir Lungengewebe und Lungenwege darstellen.
Dabei können wir Gewebeprobe entnehmen.
Das Gerät hat einen Schlauch.
Der Schlauch enthält eine Kamera und eine Lichtquelle.
Diese Untersuchung ist eine schmerzhafte Untersuchung.
Deswegen verabschieden wir während der Untersuchung örtliche Betäubung.
Örtliche Betäubung ist ein leichtes Schlafmittel.
Das ist eine Sedation.
Ein leichtes Schlafmittel.
Deswegen sollte der Patient vor der Untersuchung 6 Stunden nüchtern sein.
Nach der Untersuchung braucht der Patient eine Begleitung.
Sie können nicht Auto fahren.
Sie können nicht eine wichtige Entscheidung treffen.
Sie dürfen. Der Patient darf nicht Auto fahren.
Guten Tag Herr Oberast.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Ich würde ihn gerne Ihnen vorstellen.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit dafür?
Ich berichte über den 74-jährigen Patienten Hans-Jörg Kaiser.
Er ist 80 Kilogramm und 1,82 Meter groß.
Der Patient stellt sich seit fünf Tagen zu einem langen Bestehenden,
hüsten und gelblichen Auswurf vor.
Außerdem gibt es einen großen Schmerz.
Die Belastung ist sehr schwer.
Der Patient hat eine sehr starke Insomnie.
Er leidet seit zehn Jahren an Arterialhypertonie.
Seit 15 Jahren Typ 2 Diabetes mellitus.
Seit sieben Jahren Beninprostathyperplasie.
Seit zwei Jahren COPD.
Seit sieben Jahren hat er Phenomone erlitten,
die mit stationärer Aufnahme behandelt wurde.
Er nimmt Metformin 500 Milligramm zweimal täglich,
Metoprolol 25 Milligramm täglich morgens.
Norvask 10 Milligramm täglich.
Antiprostat Tablet 4 Milligramm täglich.
Hydrochlorothiazid 12,5 Milligramm zweimal täglich.
Und Ventolin und Pulmikort Spray beim Bedarf.
Der Patient wurde vor 20 Jahren cholecystektomiert.
Er ist vor ständig geimpft und leidet unter Hausstaubalermitteln.
Können Sie die Operation wiederholen?
Er wurde vor 20 Jahren cholecystektomiert.
Der Patient wurde vor 20 Jahren cholecystektomiert.
In der Vegetative Anamnese gab er an, dass sein Vater an Myokardial infarktus vor drei Jahren gestorben ist und seine Mutter gesund ist.
Herr Pulling, Sie haben gesagt, in der Vegetative Anamnese gab er an.
In der Familienanamnese gab er an, dass sein Vater an Myokardial infarktus vor drei Jahren gestorben ist und seine Mutter gesund ist.
Sein Bruder ist vor 15 Jahren an Bronschel-Carsenot mit 65 Jahren gestorben.
Sein Bruder?
Sein Bruder, ja.
Sein Bruder.
Er ist mit dem Rauen vor fünf Jahren aufgehört und früher hat er 60 Packung Jahre geraucht.
Er trinkt keinen Alkohol und der Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Er ist verheiratet und hat zwei gesunde Töchter erlebt mit ihrer Frau.
Die anamnestischen Angaben deuten am ehesten auf COPD-Exerservation hin.
Die Differentialdiagnostik kommen, Lungenkarzinom, Pneumonie, Herzinsuffizienz in Betracht.
Waren Sie COPD-Exerservation?
Der Patient leidet unter seit zwei Jahren Hüsten mit Auswurf und Atemnot.
Er war stark raucher.
Jetzt hat er auch Hüsten mit Auswurf, gelblich Auswurf und auch Dyspne diese Beschwerden seit COPD-Exerservation.
Um meine Verdachtstheatmosphäre zu bestätigen, würde ich zuerst den Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Besonders achte ich bei der Inspektion darauf, ob es eine jugularinere Erweiterung gibt oder Atemhilfmuskulatur-Einsatz gibt.
Oder es gibt eine Zyanose, eine Lippenzyanose, eine Zentralzyanose, ein Trommelfinger oder ein Urglasnagel.
Ich höre die Lungen ab, ob es ein verminderter Atemgeräusch gibt oder ein feuchter Rasslgeräusch oder ein trockener Rasslgeräusch.
Ich würde auch Blut abnehmen.
Ich empfehle Ihnen zuerst Vitalparameter zu messen.
Ja, natürlich. Sie haben recht, Herr Oberarzt.
Besonders welche Parameter achten Sie?
Ja, ich würde zuerst Sauerstoffsäftigung messen, ob es eine Hypoxie gibt.
Ich würde gerne auch Blutdruck messen und Fieber auch messen.
Atemfrequenz und Herzfrequenz würde ich bestimmen lassen.
Zunächst werde ich eine EKG schreiben, um mögliche Herzrhythmusstörungen auszuschließen.
Ich würde auch eine Röntgendestoraks verändern, um mögliche Herzvergrößerungen oder Lungen pathologischen Ausdruck zu machen.
Ich würde natürlich Blut abnehmen, ein großes Blutbild, Entzündungsparameter und Probenp.
Ich würde bestimmen lassen.
Ja, großes Blutbild. Ich würde bestimmen lassen, um mögliche Pneumonien auszuschließen, infektiöse Prozesse auszuschließen.
Ich würde auch Blutgasanalyse durchführen, um mögliche Blutgasanalyse bestimmen lassen.
Ich würde auch eine Hypoxie oder Blutsäure oder pH-Werte bestimmen lassen.
Und die Apparativdiagnostik würde ich auch CT-Destoraks bestimmen oder durchführen, um mögliche Lungenkarzinom auszuschließen oder Pneumonien auszuschließen.
Und gegebenenfalls, wenn es eine Befunde gibt, würde ich eine Bronchoscopy durchführen.
Und während der Bronchoscopy kann ich natürlich eine Gewehrprobe entnehmen oder mögliche Atemwegveränderungen bestimmen lassen.
Ich würde den Patienten stationär aufnehmen, um einen Venouszugang zu bekommen und ausreichende Flüssigkeit verabreichen.
Ich würde auch eine Betamematik oder einen Pulmikot oder einen Cortison durch Nasenkanüle bestimmen.
Und durch Venouszugang werde ich auch einen Cortison verabreichen und gegebenenfalls Antibiotika verabreichen.
Herr Kollegen, würden Sie den Patienten entübieren?
Jetzt würde ich nicht entübieren, aber mit den Ergebnissen würde ich entscheiden, ob der Patient eine Entübation benötigt.
In welcher Situation entscheiden Sie eine Entübation?
Wenn der pH-Wert sehr gering ist und der Sauerstoff sehr gering ist, wenn der Patient die Orientierung verloren hat,
und der Sauerstoff nicht atmen kann, würde ich entübieren.
Die Entübung ist unter 60%.
80 oder 60?
80.
Herr Oberass, ja.
Können Sie uns eine EKG aufklären?
EKG heißt Elektrokardiographie.
Mit Hilfe der EKG können wir Herz-Elektrik-Aktivitäten messen.
Mit Klemmen, wie Klemmen, Extremität, 4 Extremitäten und auf dem Brustkorb müssen wir 6 Metallgerätklemmen.
Und mit Hilfe der EKG können wir Herzrhythmus, möglicher Herzinfarkt oder Herzvergrößerung oder Herzschwache bestätigen.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Ich würde Ihnen gerne den Patienten vorstellen.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, gerne.
Es handelt sich um Hans Jung-Kaiser.
Herr Kaiser ist 74 Jahre alt, 1 Meter 82 groß und 80 Kilogramm schwer.
Der Patient stellt sich heute bei uns wegen seit 5 Tagen bestehender, starke Tussis mit Belastung abhängiger Dyspnövo.
Der Patient hat geblische Weizen, Sputum und Hemoptisi.
Desweiteren klagt er über Belastung abhängiger Dyspnövo.
Die Beschwerden gehen mit Asteni, Fatigue, Pfeifen, der Geräusch einher.
Der Patient belastet über eine Gewichtabnahme mit 10 Kilogramm innerhalb von einem Jahr.
Der Patient ist deswegen bei seinem Hausarzt gewesen.
Der Arzt hat gesagt, dass er COPD hat.
Die Einnahme von Weissspray wie Ventolin kann wollen.
Das hat ein bisschen Verbesserung gebracht.
Die Vegetative Anamnese hat Folgendes ergeben.
Inapedens, Insomni, Nackschweiss, Niktur und Tachycardi.
Anfängerkranken sind seit 2005 eine Prostathyperplase.
Seit 2005 ein arteriales Hyperton.
Seit 5 Jahren Diabetes.
Dagegen nimmt er Metaprolol 25 mg täglich.
Norvask 10 mg täglich.
Hydrochlorothiazid 12,5 mg täglich.
Antiprostat Tablet 4 mg täglich.
Metformin 500 mg täglich.
Der Patient wurde vor 20 Jahren bei einem Kolesistektom durchgeführt.
Früher hat er mit 7 Jahren bei ihm eine Phenomone festgestellt.
Er wurde mit einer Antibiotika im Krankenhaus behandelt.
Mit 7 Jahren.
Als er Kind war.
Der Patient hatte eine Hauptstoppallergie.
Die sich mit Schnupfen und trennenden Augen äußerte.
Früher hat er nicht Rauchen.
Vor 5 Jahren hat er mit dem Rauchen aufgehört.
Früher hat er 20 Jahre lang ein Schachtel Zigaretten geraucht.
Alkohol und Drogenkonsum.
Im Besuch auf Familienanamnese.
Teilt er mit, dass der Vater mit 88 Jahre alt.
an einem Myokarteninfarkt ist.
Die Mutter ist gesund.
Sein Bruder mit 65 Jahren.
hat ein Bronchialkarsinoma verstorben.
Er ist vollständig geimpft.
Er ist Lehrer.
Er ist verheiratet.
Er hat zwei Töchter.
Die Kinder sind gesund.
Er lebt mit seiner Frau.
Ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf eine COPD aus.
Da der Patient typische Symptome aufweist.
Der Patient leidet unter Dispnö, Tussis, Schuputum, Engagefühl.
Außerdem hat der Patient sehr lange mit Lungenproblemen.
Er hat viele chronische Erkrankungen.
Wie Arterielle Hypertonie und Diabetes mellitus.
Diese Erkrankungen sind sehr wichtig für den Körper.
Als Differenzialdiagnose kommen auch Pneumone, Bronchialkarsinoma und chronische Herzkrankungen.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, werde ich den Patienten bei den Patienten die Vitaparameter überwachen.
Dann werde ich den Patienten körperliche Untersuchung.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung.
Ich habe die Widerstandsparameter überwacht.
Dann werde ich den Patienten körperlich unterdrücken.
Dabei der Körpersche unterdrücken.
Ich werde darauf achten, ob Zyanose, Ödeme, Fastoraks, Hype, Sonar,
Klappschall, Gimmel, Brummen, Pfeifen vorlegen.
Neben den körperlichen Untersuchungen
wären Laberunterzuchungen sinnvoll, um eine umfassende Diagnostik zu gewährleisten.
Dabei werde ich eine große Blutbildung,
CRP, BSG, Elektrolyte, BMP, Tropon,
die Ansündungsparameter bestimmen lassen.
Dann werde ich den Patienten
mit dem Körpersche unterdrücken.
Dann werde ich die Diagnose bestimmen.
Dann werde ich den Patienten mit dem Körpersche unterdrücken.
Sollte sich meine Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen,
werde ich den Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Zunächst werde ich den Patienten einen Benüzenszugang vorlegen.
Danach werde ich den Patienten eine Analgetik und
eine Antikollinergie und Teophilin verabreichen.
Wenn es nötig ist, werde ich den Patienten eine Antibiotika verabreichen.
Außerdem werde ich den Patienten eine Pneumonikkonzil anordnen,
um eine Therapie und die Therapie des Patienten zu optimieren.
Wenn Sie mit dieser Vorgehensweise einverstanden sind,
werde ich den Planken unterdrücken durch Fortfahren von der Öberarztin.
Danke schön für diese Information Herr Dr.
Aber wann hat der Patient die COPD diagnostiziert?
Vor zwei Jahren war der Patient bei Ihrem Hausarzt.
Der Hausarzt hat gesagt, dass der Patient COPD hat.
Aber es ist eine genügend Diagnose.
Ich habe keine Ahnung von der Öberarztin.
Wie viele Exzerserbationen hat der Patient im Leser?
Ich habe nicht gefragt von der Öberarztin.
Es war gefragt, aber ich habe nicht gehört.
Nein, niemand gehört.
Aber jetzt hat der Patient eine Atemnot.
Ja, der Patient hat die Atemnot besprochen.
Seit zwei Jahren.
Aber die Symptome sind in der Ferne der Zeit immer schlimmer geworden.
Der Patient hat jetzt eine starke Atemnot.
Sie hat eine Dispneus aus Sputum und Tussis.
Okay, denken Sie COPD Exzerserbation?
Ja, Sie haben recht Frau Dr.
Was ist COPD?
COPD ist chronische obstetive Lungenerkrankung.
Welche Krankheiten ist es?
COPD ist eine Lungenluftwegekrankung.
Okay, also Bronchiole oder Bronchiektase oder Cronchitis.
Lungenenfizem.
Das ist ein effektives Lungenkrankung.
Ja, Sie haben recht Frau Dr.
Ich habe keine Erfahrung über das Thema.
Nach der Prüfung werde ich dieses Thema recherchieren.
Okay, welche Differentialdiagnosen müssen Sie ausschließen?
Wiederholen?
Pneumonie, Bronchialcarcinoma und Cronchias Krankheit.
Ja, chronische Herzkrankheit.
Was meinen Sie? Chronische Herzkrankheit?
Herzinfizienz oder?
Ja, Herzinfizienz.
Okay, welche Untersuchungen für diese Krankheit ausschließen?
Der Patient hat gewisse Abnahmen, deswegen können wir Bronchialcarcinoma denken.
Um Bronchialcarcinoma ausschließen, werde ich eine Sprometrie durchführen.
Sprometrie oder Jasprometrie?
Jasprometrie.
Wenn es eine Auffälligkeit oder Schwierigkeiten gibt,
werde ich eine Probeaufnahme für Laborunterzüge für Bronchialcarcinoma ausschließen.
Aber gegebenenfalls werde ich CT-Torax und MRT-Torax durchführen um mögliche Tumore ausschließen.
Wenn ich um KHK ausschließen werde ich den Patienten EKG und Eschokardiografie durchführen.
Ich habe weitere Fragen. Welche Maßnahmen für Residivprophylaxe gibt es?
Oder was empfehlen Sie den Patienten nach der Therapie?
Nach der Therapie empfehle ich den Patienten Gewicht, aber der Patient hat nicht über Gewicht.
Er hat eine Lungeninfektion.
Der Patient hat viele Chronische Erkrankungen für Diabetes mellitus.
Die psychologischen Werte zu kontrollieren sind sehr wichtig.
Was müssen die Patienten für Schutz in dieser Krankheit?
Ich verstehe nicht die Frage.
Der Patient hat viele Risikofaktoren.
Wie empfehlen Sie den Patienten für Schutz?
Empfehlen Sie diesen Patienten einige Impfungen?
Ja, Sie haben recht.
Wir empfehlen den Patienten Influenza-Impfung und COVID-Impfung.
Möchten Sie eine Blutgasanalyse durchführen?
Ja, wir müssen eine Blutgasanalyse durchführen.
Warum ist eine Blutgasanalyse so wichtig?
Blutgasanalyse ist wichtig. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Warum?
Welche Therapie leiten Sie sofort ein?
Die Akute Therapie ist sehr wichtig.
Zunächst werden die Patienten mit Sauerstoff-Sättigung und
und 2-sympathomimetika, Teofilin, wie Brankodilatatoren und inhalative Glucocholid.
Antibiotika ist notwendig?
Ja, wenn es notwendig ist, ist Antibiotika sehr wichtig.
Was sind die häufigsten Ursachen für eine Exzerserbation?
Ich denke, eine Jungeninfektion ist wichtig.
Hat der Patient eine Geschichte?
Der Patient hat als Kind in Kurszeit gefragt.
Der Patient hat seit 2 Jahren diese Probleme.
In 2 Wochen oder in einem Monat hat der Patient eine Infektion.
Oder hat der Patient einige Allergien.
Oder der Patient hat eine Sauerstoff-Allergien. Das ist ein Risikofaktor.
Das kann eine Exzerserbation machen?
Ja, es könnte sein, dass wegen dieser Allergie eine Rekurrenz möglich ist.
Aber der Patient hat eine Infektion, das ich nicht gehört habe.
Oder das ich nicht gefragt habe.
Ich bin ein Gefragter.
Okay.
Deine Fragen sind sehr schön, aber ich habe sie nicht gefragt.
Ich habe sie nicht gehört.
Nein, aber wenn man etwas über das Allergien überlegt hat,
sollte man die Risikofaktoren fragen.
Aber wenn man eine Allergie hat,
dann muss man die Risikofaktoren fragen.
Das könnte man fragen.
Yusuf, bist du hier? Warum hast du dich nicht gefragt?
Ich habe so viele Fragen.
Welchen du jetzt fragen wirst?
Ich bin auf dich.
Du hast recht.
Ich hätte es gerne nicht so leicht fragen können.
Ich habe mir viele Dinge überlegt.
Aber ich sehe mich hier auf der einen Seite.
Es ist zehn Minuten vorbei.
Ich muss jetzt auf die Frage gehen.
Die Fragen sind noch nicht vorbei.
Aber es ist nicht gut.
Man könnte sogar die Anwendung fragen.
Es gibt etwas um die Arthrose.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du das gefragt hast.
Ich habe die Anwendung nicht gefragt.
Ich habe es gesagt.
Die Anwendung ist zehn Minuten lang.
Ich muss jetzt auf die andere Frage gehen.
Der Patient hat ein Kiloverlust.
Er hat eine Anwendung im Körper.
Er könnte vielleicht die Anwendung fragen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du das gefragt hast.
Ich habe es gesagt.
Ich hätte es gerne fragen können.
Aber Yusuf macht etwas.